all right and we are live welcome to the
last word with more [ __ ] beetle and a
Bartis can't fire starting to heat up
early a lot of things to talk about a
lot of redacted things to talk about
ah already in da face I'm just getting
game so but anyway we're happy to be
back at the last were so what's going on
Eman how's your week been what's been
going on with you ah week's been pretty
good Tuesday was a little chaotic mmm I
don't know if you slept through most of
I think the chaos logged in on Tuesday
and Kenna
a couple things went to go check my
currencies I got robbed in the middle of
the night oh yeah I was like lost like
two-thirds of my shards I lost like damn
prisms damn I all my upgrade modules
were gone so like all the important
stuff is what seemed to get like taken
away I lost like 200,000 glimmer and on
top of it somebody like went in my back
room and got like a couple unstable
charges of light they took those two
horrible bro I don't even want to know
what that feels like like I saw the
tweets going out it was you it was
Tassie I was like oh I'm not logging in
I'm not longer did we I saw it I asked
him oh yeah so I logged in and I was
like what so I was like kind of
concerned I was like hey the longer I
stay in am I gonna like register this
bad data site later just logged out
about an hour later they took the
service down so they were only live for
maybe an hour an hour and a half and
then they took him down so anybody who
did anything in that time mm-hmm
they had it that work was basically
taken away because they rolled back to
pre patch which is basically 8:30 that
morning so wasn't that long but it was
long enough that like I think one person
tweeted it's like oh it feels bad that
somebody like got the hive armaments mod
in that hour and a half I thought oh
yeah about that oh so like what if you
got like 1,000 places I don't care
what's going on honestly because I
figured it was like they're gonna
have to go back to like an old image I
don't think they're just gonna like
shove currencies and everybody sells
like I'm not gonna do anything not worth
it going down no yeah Sports bought me a
smart man yeah yeah getting home to do
all that would did me nothing so then
finally about 9 o'clock came around and
it's like oh it's back mmm yes what
about you sleeping through it all mr.
vampire yeah I mean I had all intentions
to play and then I saw I saw the news
and you know you guys gave me a good
jolt of fear and I said I am NOT doing
it and I kept peeking my head out to see
what it was safe and yeah that I saw the
news go out and um I just wanted to
comment on that because actually it
really resonated with me because um
obviously I work in IT and I used to do
disaster recovery for a while so um look
the situation we definitely you know you
don't wish that on any game it's one of
those things that you know whatever the
patch this patch did you know it
definitely broke the game and in the
safe state of what people had took away
things which is a strange bug that it
took home waiting so that's scary yeah
right so my whole thing was okay they
did it they must have realized it wasn't
you know a widespread problem and then
at that point they do the rollback now
this is what people understand like
companies in theory are supposed to have
these you know working and tested I
could tell you working as an IT admin
how many companies are truly not
prepared for a large-scale rollback and
disaster recovery and I've seen other
games do this which are single-player
games or whatever just different games
and not to the scope of that but that's
this living world just breathing them
and more all these moving parts all
these currencies all these things and
for them to do it now granted it yeah of
course it took a while this is server
recovery this is backup recovery but for
them to do it and then put you at that
same state which means that backups were
accurate their backups were on time they
were they were constant we're doing full
and incremental backups and to put you
back at that state unscathed pretty much
you just lost an hour of work or
whatever but you got all your stuff back
that is tremendous and I don't I want to
I know it's weird to give them kudos on
a patch mess up but at the end of the
day if you don't have good recovery
backups you're through you could be
through as it as a game as a company so
salute to their their IT team their
server team because I know what that
hell is I've been in those rooms I've
been in the server room
it's a chaotic feeling so don't know
that though that there and this system
that's in place the infrastructure in
place it's really good you know salute
to them and um being today you know you
got your stuff back man you know it
sucked but hey we live through it we're
still here that's not look at me but
seriously it's like I mean there were
but not a patch so I was like I honestly
wonder how frequently they do the backup
because I was like hey is it on like a
daily basis is it you know before daily
reset they do it cuz it was 8:30 we
humbly win it finished her had that data
pulled it's kind of like an image and
then the net they took things down and
started getting the patch so was the
like before the patch is this weekly is
this daily I kind of wonder how frequent
they actually do it as mine I can only
guess to how big their images yeah my
guesstimate is because of the size but
you dealing with a game of that scope
you know because of the sky that's the
size of it they wouldn't be able to do
like I would assume they wouldn't be
able to do like two or three different
backups on a day so they probably have a
full backup a weekly backup and they
have to have a daily backup I don't like
a set time and in a day I said so maybe
they do it right before a reset you know
say you know what or whatever as a safe
stay so that's my guess usually with
with companies and servers of that size
I would assume that cuz though those are
that's a lot of storage that's a lot of
data to be backing up that's it that's
not cheap that's done that's what I
would assume they're probably in their
case yeah at this point for everybody
back up your data back it up back it up
yeah you have extra storage
save your important stuff in a fireproof
safe safety deposit box I mean there you
go two copies cannot be safe enough that
was no par five what's going on dramatic
what's going on in the faces coming in
by the campfires getting hot I like that
you like warm you're gathering a crowd
weirdness right Carlin huddle in yo it's
story time guys story time I was gonna
say how was iron banner for you and we
wrapped that
last week did you get to play me did you
care about it lunchtime you know shout
out to my man game before tea we will
rock it out for a little bit um kind of
play a bit of banner with him um mostly
knocked out all my pinnacles you know
say got that done um actually because of
Forte telling me because I need my
savior title that I have to get those
ritual weapons so I got decide on how I
was done that arms that was easy but I
was very easy
yeah very quick um right now working on
Komodo I got the hardest parts done I
got the the head the precision kills and
I got the volume kills now I just got to
get my behind and comp and just play
regular I don't have to play with it now
it was am but I will say this are
blessed
I was I was getting busy with our blast
likes yo the little cheat y'all have got
like bad things head tracking auto
forgive wrong stupid man
it's stupid aim assist did he hit you
[ __ ] it was crazy over here you know
yeah well you can aim my hair and it's
to giving you a head shot credit the big
that's crazy doe is throw on the season
mod linear fusion aim assist enhance but
it's wrong - oh yeah brah it is read you
out like yo this is crazy like people
were rushing me sometimes I get a body
shot and a shotgun ache was coming at me
and I still have enough time to get
another body I don't know
it's crazy so I just do that on I had
linear fusion scavenger I was real
sweaty I was real sweaty but I didn't
care I got it done so now just an hour
oh yeah did you guys do it's a matter of
getting in there surprisingly the one
that's taking the longest that's a it's
not hard it's just long yeah grinds just
every one of those seems just long and
whatever reason you're just like there's
so many matches I gotta do shotguns you
gotta use I mean you could go triple
shotgun if you want to I mean he's a
curious I hear some people use them and
that's an option yeah technically
tractor cannon is one too don't forget
about that if you're going in there so
you got a couple oh yeah
things like that that can get you some
more big beefy kills if you want to use
them being void is helpful in there
yeah I gotta go more shotgun sweaty I
guess cuz right now I'm doing Lord of
wolves but I think my problem is to
close up kills and because Lord of
wolves is technically a pole shot yeah I
mean so I think that's what my spikes my
close-up shot gun kills are really going
slow mind if I go pull em here I closed
or something like that
might do that my year might go I close
and they're like you say baby boop boop
cannon I don't have accurate on PC that
all my Xbox account I haven't run Lamont
in unarmed what you'd call it on peace
like I've got it on PC I don't have the
full I have like one stage binder but I
haven't done pressed yes Leviathan I'm
just got the yeah to shot whatever yeah
man I used to have all that fun stuff so
I got to get that back and get that
going to get that quest off my my thing
yeah read more man it's like I never
read like every I gotta go I gotta get
more raids going man that's definitely
on me but I will say this shout-out to
PC LMG I mean they've been impressive
yeah I got I got it just jumping in do
it I I'm very impressed what I'm saying
is always stuff they did it running all
the time mmhmm yeah
Aaron kills deer in chat he's like don't
have me with gambit yesterday played 21
matches for break Nick 19 ago like I
remember that grind oh yeah I remember a
deck it's a grind that is a crime you
know I'm telling you right now yeah
trust me it thank God for forgive it
prime though at least it's one round
you're gonna say goddamn but yeah that
gambit man yeah you feel it's a task you
feel heck
I don't know it's something about like
when you're like you know you guys I
have so many matches like breakneck was
like 40 matches you're like that just I
mean that's 400 minutes at a minimum if
you're lucky like if you're lucky and
then matchmaking lately like the time
between matches recently and Crucible -
I just sit there waiting I'm like am I
ever late I feel like me to read or what
like read two full articles or like
watch like I'm like I'm going on to like
my next YouTube video as I wait somebody
just built an entire PCD of my waiting
time what does happen right now dude it
is it's I think it's a you know we'll
talk about things later but you know one
of the things that has to happen it's
just just too many cues there's just too
many and unfortunately they gotta clean
that up before other things can come you
know as a whole so yeah I agree
yeah so what caused the whole big
screw-up of like losing currencies and
like 10 hours of server time was a
passion well that patch actually finally
went live so update 2.7 1.1 had some
good things in there some changes couple
weapons that people might want actually
pull out of the vault and see what's
going on one we just mentioned hmm but a
quick run-through you had things like
activities pit of heresy like there's
the transition between zones that was
killing people so flawless runs were
having issues that's been fixed that
sucks
a Garden of salvation the tethering is a
bit more visually obvious that that
thing - tether sources on yeah that's a
big deal
nightfall ordeals have been like reduced
to like one two and three as opposed to
like one to five or something like that
so just the number of ordeal completions
you'll need two biggest ones
wanted to see if you'd trade either of
them rampage proper stacking damage with
onslaught on breakneck mmm hasn't been
adjusted yes
kind of sort of now watch the house
across this video about that because he
was able to I guess like jump in and try
it in that like hours before it got shut
down and it looks like the damage is
better but there's all like new
precision damage changes and stuff like
that since shadow Keenan
but also when it comes to like rampage
damage times three it knocks it down
again it's like it builds it builds and
then it goes faster so you've like 600
rpm so normal rate then it goes up to
600 rpm so it doesn't change it then
it's 600 km with more damage and then it
just goes a higher rpm but like lowers
the damage you'll always do damage and
it like lowers it to far he was his
numbers were just like I was like that
doesn't seem right so I mean it's not
awful mmm the rampage spec on there and
still doing some pretty good things but
just yeah if you can get rampage up to x
3 with that auto rifle you may as well
just be able to moon mow people down for
just a little while like feels like it I
mean you go through 40 game but matches
and you bash your head against that for
a little while you may as well enjoy you
know putting the rampage spec not on
there and then just you know actually
enjoying if you get two times three
you're like oh I'm not doing as much I
mean you fire fast but it just could be
better I don't know I know they're
worried about rampage x 3 breaking some
yeah they terrify the terrified of it
that's all these they are scared of
rampage that 3 that's all this is they
are trying to make sure this thing is
not a de facto thing which I don't like
because I mean like you said the effort
required to getting that gun you know
this is this is during the era of the
pinnacle and it was yeah it was a lot of
grind you know I'm saying so it's just
like come don't decrease or the third
level of rampage even much like not as
much as it is like maybe keep it
somewhat along but it feels like it's a
good uh and then just dick amenities
going like are if you're gonna go down
you're so scared on the third one why
can't it just go back to like level one
you know I'm saying like
rampage one or something still give a
little bit of damage buff for maximum
DPS so you can feel like you're doing
some and I'm saying like you line up
three kills
it's like let me enjoy it let me enjoy
it man
Oh Rollie didn't taketh away
now another auto-rifle that got a little
boost it's mostly not even a boost it's
just late crowd the bowl a little bit
and uh adjusted scope feedback and
camera shake on hard light I don't know
if you've tried it or pulled it from
your vault it's well I've seen it
I see now I'm being killed by it all the
time catalyst I don't have it finished
but I've got it and it's gonna take the
stability to a hundred yes that is so if
you don't have it it's gonna just laser
that thing in and no damage drop off all
three types and gve for night falls and
it's not green it's not like ya do it
all the craziness yep now you got the
ricochet damage to I mean it's it Harl
eyes would be shot the chi on that home
yes I said he said how long's good now
it's definitely good enough he's a he
was a hard life fan before buff now so
he's in heaven now he's just mad like oh
you guys daddy's market ah
daddy's got the buff you know hmm couple
other things like nothing major but
there's two I read him like why why does
this even matter fixed an issue where
leviathans breath and zeno phage started
PvE activities mind you with more ammo
than intended
like unless you're giving me 50 on
leviathans breath or like 6000 on
xenophanes like if it's within the cap
yeah like yeah I hate it when they're
like no you can't start with too much
ammo like I should have a full ammo what
the hell
mm-hmm that's just me uh I don't know if
you guys had a chance to try a worm God
caress or winters guile they're back
they were available and then they're not
again mm mm shut those down within a day
cuz I just literally saw glads tweet
after servers went up on Wednesday yeah
when servers went up he's like oh
they're still broken and Bungie shut him
down again it's like are you serious
they were they weren't even of 24 hours
up and they're already broken again
already broke
hmm the change around some mods trying
to think of any other major stuff there
was some tweaking uh gameplay things
like sunbreakers tighten mortar blast
was like 70% PvE
I was like yeah apparently that thing
was terrible before but didn't even know
it
Titans were healing themselves by
bouncing hammers off although you could
do those things yeah there's a lot of
experts to Bailey this was a big yeah a
fixed nation where his role which
roaring flames was buffing solar weapon
damage while standing in a Wella Brady
and some like didn't even know
apparently now the one that you might
enjoy fixed an issue that prevented
warlocks from using blink after
switching weapons or can't seeing these
big big ding-ding-ding yeah I got to
stop using blink in em PvE cuz I use it
on PvE sometimes and it's just like that
switching and even PvP is just like like
I felt like there's my controller
lagging like it's not being responsive
and then I realized oh this is
definitely a thing that's been going on
yeah that's been for the void locks yeah
I've been feeling it man and I know
about that one so China the dust that
blinked back off and get that going john
denofa being petty say he never got to
try these exploits that's like I didn't
even know there were things though man
the biggest one is probably for all of
you related to the black armor in
izanagi's they seem to have made getting
that rare bounty especially a lot more
reliable players that complete all
available weekly and daily bounties will
acquire a rare bounty within 5 days oh I
don't know if you have to do like all 7
bounties and then do the dailies every
day I'm not entirely sure how to read
that one I'm sure how we didn't read
that no weekly I agree with you it's
it's worded strangely right it's like do
you complete all seven and then get a
guaranteed like five days log in and
it's there like every day for five days
yeah that's worded very strangely but I
will say this that rare bounty is a huge
part of that quest and you know having
to deal with orangey on that part and
you have no control under when you are
getting it there never was that again
exactly like that was a problem so I'm
glad
they address that you know and then like
I said for people who have jumped in
post black armory it's not like the days
of you know that when you could just hit
the director and pick any Boris you know
you got the other RNG daily orangey of
which forage appears actually on the e
disease shallots are cars going back but
a hump yeah so just like it's all this
little extra orangey and stuff like that
so it's like guys if you ever get please
work on your Izanagi daily knock it out
get it done you definitely want that in
your repertoire yeah and solid your
catalyst it only takes one prestige run
in mmm-hmm menagerie knocked that one
out this year like a weekend or two ago
no and it's really not that bad like
prestige now didn't even heal that bad
like we were doing it knocked it out
pretty fast it's pretty good like I said
the LF G's have been smoking or nose
again PC Xbox like you can get it done I
got mines done literally you know I put
little requests in and it was like
literally 10 minutes nice full room boom
ready to go well I got a question for
you sir
yeah so you have Amazon Prime
I do do you have twitch prom I do you
can go claim some stuff in game and
these are exotic cosmetics by the way
before you get interested about it hmm
so basically the bungee and dusty - is
paired up with twitch prime so you guys
I've seen the rewards real like oh
what's this reward oh here's this random
in-game thing boom same idea is make
sure your account is logged in on your
Bungie page go to twitch Brian claim
your stuff and it's there's a ship
there's two right now this month is like
the Saros exotic ornaments and then
there's a ghost in there as well so I
think they're just gonna be putting some
ever verse stuff into twitch prime
honestly just ways for you know company
used to coincide and work together do
you think this is a big deal do you even
care what you just like I probably have
it all already any thoughts on this um
you know me did I don't mind
ornaments exotics yeah I mean cirrhosis
ain't hurt nobody so I'm not mad at that
per se you know Sam but I want to see
where this goes you know me always gonna
keep my eye on them and then I say just
to see where it goes but autumn in
sparing me a lot of this stuff is you
know older stuff I want a shout out to
ask the cross you know definitely seem
to be gearing towards you know the
players who like destiny you know what I
just haven't played to and you know
they're kind of bringing back sir those
type of weapons if you're a deep layer B
one player you understand you know I
know sir us was that thing you know is
that like mad super matter now but you
know kind of thing I mean it's older
stuff about crazy now again we have to
monitor its early it's sometimes we know
how our good friends do yes they with
sneaking digs if you get all six months
worth that last one's gonna be an exotic
good grab exact you doing so right now
okay so questions don't mean much anyway
anymore they really don't they don't
less people are like suit I will give my
left arm for a void Luna faction boots
or something like that before asking for
it and then they get if they get one
it's trash or whatever no if it stays
Cosmetics I don't care
I really don't stays cosmetic that's
fine but it better not be I'm gonna not
be seeing devil vu and tight guns in
there
you know new stuff that you ain't can't
see in game them yeah you're gonna hear
me you're gonna hear me I love ya I'll
fix your face I see you just making
faces but I'm telling you right they are
good at big dick if they keep it like
this I'm fine just we gotta watch that's
all they've been known inch into a mile
and known as they've been honestly good
have you seen this ever verse door
I'm saying it still cosmetics mall exam
have you seen our drops yes I know I
know IRS's the ever first store I'm
aware okay having you are you are a
dungeon connoisseur would you say oh I
don't believe me there was like witty I
quote a theory of like an armor set from
the dungeon I know wouldn't you like
some of the same stuff that we're
getting into battle pass and in the ever
verse there's a bigger argument there as
much how I look if armor 2.0 is still
kind of wasting my time so alright but
that's that's another issue that's a
marble to borrow is another issue how
many would we keep talking about how
much resources do they have I would
rather they like make armor 2.0 said oh
let's go oh that's go and get like we
we're getting it man let's go tag me in
now we let this one look are you ready
to tell me that you think that because
of the pinnacle reward Cosmetics they
don't have enough resources to they
don't have reason to turn the energy the
manpower to put in desirable ornaments
and armor sets from cosmetic standpoint
so we talk about you are okay with this
being solely in the ever versus or is
that what you're saying sir I just want
to be clear be clear here
Louis yours there we go it my team it
was not about that my argument was I
would drove him spend those resources of
doing any of that type of stuff mm-hmm
work on armor make it better make it
more make it matter more to ending
something ever stuff could absolutely be
in the game 100% agree yes with you 100%
mm-hmm and if you're gonna say hey
you're designing for armor sets 3.9 of
them should not be an ever verse I agree
with that
yeah I've never I'm really I just don't
like all the resources of the did the
art let's be honest our team is amazing
these monuments are amazing everything
emotes amazing just can we get a little
bit back in the game based on gameplay
like I miss those days baby that's not
love but yeah IIIi agree that I grabbed
that you jumped off the roof for a
second channel I mean you also get okay
so consider this though to and it's one
of those where like raids like one of
the things that set those other armor
sets apart was like the hard mode we
don't even have the hard mode to make
those distinctions anymore so I think it
would be fair to do ornaments for like
the challenges yes thing I mean they do
um I don't know if they have a challenge
for every single room but I mean just do
a challenge you get an ornament maybe
you do five challenges even if it's the
same fighter like one fifth challenge
gets you that full ordnance in and again
like those are hard things to do and
then you wouldn't even have to per se
where that armor would be an ornament
you could slap on anything and enjoy a
more Universal ornament by doing a
challenge I would completely love that
and I think that would definitely calm
down people who are looking at the of of
our store with a very listen we know why
it's there we know it needs to exist we
definitely know this it they're on their
own finances are of our importance but
um like I said they just need to have a
little balance with the gameplay guys
cuz you want to you want people to go in
there for repeatable you know objectives
you know repeat like Bannock I got a
shot at that armor I got a shot at that
that cool thing that I saw but that's
kind of the hook for a repetitive
gameplay and I just don't want them to
lose sight of that because I feel since
shadow
they they really pivoted in this ever
verse only don't you know direct oh yeah
preach it preach it yeah yeah preach it
but I'll submit on the other side like
these nano phoenix ship mm-hmm from
wrath of the machine the nano Phoenix is
one people granted out forever what if
there was just like a really one they
have so many like ships and stuff that
they do one of those exotic ships like
make it the most badass of all of them
and put it in like the strike playlist
or something I'm like ah just a random
like Oh point zero one percent chance
you never know somebody gets a be like
oh I got a ship from doing the strike
because this this right and be like and
it could just say source rare from
strike play listen you just like Max and
people might play a few more strike like
hey I'll go do my bounty see if I get
that
and it could sit out there for a whole
year and you might never get it but
there's that little piece in the back
your head as you're playing through that
strike playlist most little Ward's in
there totally suck I'll be honest yeah
the entire strike playlist is almost
useless so at least there'd be like hey
maybe I'll get this thing maybe I won't
but that type of stuff would be nice too
I agree shout to spidey sense Kings full
ship with sweet yes it was I remember
those are the things you miss man those
things that stand out you're like the
whisper whisper was unique because it
had a gun you had the ship over the
course of like your three runs you had
the catalyst yes like you have so much
from that one mission and I feel like
that was done so well and or they made
so much money from that one to pay for
other things because it was cool you
could spend your time in there you'd
have to go back in there and you're like
man I spent like six runs in here yeah I
guess I'll buy an ornament of course
because I put so much time into this one
thing mmm very true
but yes no I agree with you that ever
verse is heavy-handed at this point for
what it holds I would like to see them
and again all these things people ask
for strike specific rewards vendor
resets I mean there's a lot of different
ways to do these things I mean things
like vendor resets at this point I think
the idea of the way the obelisks are
done like leveling them up yes and like
hey here's a couple mods new mods in the
game cool here's a couple weapons here's
some hurts to like you know here's a
part for Eid easy well at some point in
the season the flash points likely to be
each plane at almost twice what because
there's what seven or eight of them now
mmm so somewhere when you make it to
that planet or if you're like hey I'm
gonna go run some lost sectors hey in
lost sectors you get a higher chance at
fill-in-the-blank but just just give me
something all those types of things and
then make them like year-long or just
continue to like a I don't know but
there are ways to take some of the stuff
there like testing and just disperse it
to more of the game to give everything
else a little bit of value completely
we came to talk about we have the Tawaf
this week and we know what's coming next
week so for those of you guys haven't
heard I hope you have been farming your
fractal line you better how much you got
I'm curious actually or a thousand II
you know let me you're not bad yeah like
what I'm definitely at the four thousand
one slow mo what's going on sir slow
more in a building yeah mmm-hmm so after
the hiccup on Tuesday we knew we had a
slob coming because next week and
Spassky and I Artie was out we know all
quarters of time stuff next week is the
Imperium foundation this is basically
our last kind of major thing on the
calendar would you say mm-hmm
oh I will read this one straight out and
then we shall discuss let's get to it
all right so the empyrion foundation
next week the imperium foundation
rebuild effort begins saint-14 will ask
all guardians to contribute building a
beacon that will be a foundation for
things to come next season
hum I wonder if that mean what what
could have redacted the tower obelisk
will be the focal point of this event so
be sure you have it unlocked and ready
to go as it is going to have some hefty
benefits to take advantage of players
will need to come together to contribute
resources toward a common goal the
participate players can donate their
fractal izing fractal line using the
tower obelisk the event will have seven
stages each requiring increasing amounts
of fractal and to progress through there
also be a hologram at the tower where
you can able to track the community
progress in game I do have to pause
that's amazing
got a check isn't that cool you could
track something any game you can do this
is amazing yeah like how do you get a
community involved that you track it in
game that's a maze and you can look and
be like look I made it bump like and
everyone can see their progress what
that is remarkable of course we aren't
gonna ask you to fork over your
hard-earned Frank a lot fractal and
without providing some benefits here's
what's in it for you contributing to the
Imperium foundation cost 100 Polaris rec
:
contributing generates a 25% flat
progression for all time lost weapon
bounties in your inventory mega to that
one hmm your Tower obelisk will generate
polarized fractal and for you each week
equivalent to its resonance power
increase its residents power by
upgrading other obelisks so I don't know
he'll know what other so I have all of
mine at 11 the other two they want to
get them to up to like 15 or 20 and like
are you wasted by putting it in there
I don't know it's weird so we'll say um
players who donate more than 5,000
polarize fact line before the end of the
season will earn the triumph and emblem
seen below hmm ever in the community
will also receive a shader when all
stages are complete here's a look at the
community goals for the seven stages 400
million in 700 million Wow
1.2 billion and then stage 4 5 6 & 7 all
question marks which somebody was saying
they're probably going to watch and
adjust depending on how the community
like how fast they go through it how
fast they but I'll do it here now the
older the other thing is I hope they
don't like skew it to be like oh you
guys don't need to like 1.2 million on
the first day and be like that's
everything we saved up you better not
screw us on the last ones cuz if
everybody just like dumps everything on
day 1 it's like cool or we got and we're
like ok we're on stage 4 you can't make
stage 7 like 3 times as far cuz people
have been saving this stuff up for like
two months you're not gonna be able to
get as much in the last month so mmm
hopefully the numbers are reasonable so
data mined efforts were fairly accurate
I mean stuff we heard out there the
magic 5,000 numbers seem to be a phase
what do you think we're not covering
what this could be for just what do you
think about the foundation the efforts
and just kind of another community
project he's got me on the NDA y'all
because y'all know what I want to talk
about so I can't so based on the
information that is provided on screen
you know another community of a style
event you know um you know we the data
miners were on the ball
you know they hinted that this would be
something to that nature that we would
need 5000 tractor line for something you
know I this is what I consider cool
tricks to get the community involved
during a slow period you know saying now
I still like the thought of it and as
long as they continue the lore aspect of
it and handle it in the same way they
handled saint-14 story the same way they
doing the narrative banter and if they
do that well I just don't want to show
up and like you know we're just reading
text
yes Guardian it's done Osiris
say it are happy you don't say like
sometimes that loses the weight you know
times and so it's just like you know you
really if you're gonna do community only
events and in this respect you know you
want it to have that that reverent what
you needed to have that that reverence
that respect of what we are building is
important and you know and put some
weight on it you know what I'm saying so
um yeah that's it yes I do know Pig
Latin and I'm not gonna do it cuz easy
I'll get mad at me and I can't he got me
on the NDAA down that's the new thing me
Hollywood well that's what I got on
Imperium foundation that we know of so
far me yeah we I mean I do like me I'm
kind of wondering as you know we're
gonna be basically contributing
everything toward a common goal can a
building whatever rebuild efforts I'm
then the sake building a beacon I will
honestly wonder if they have like art
stages set up for like the stage as we
go through yeah like if the tower
obelisk is truly kind of the base of
something were constructing hmm so the
way they have this seven or whatever
seven eight nine weeks where we went
through for the portal
honestly wonder as the stages progressed
like hey hit stage one tower looks
different mmm I honestly I don't know
where whatever we're building is gonna
be located right they seems Towe
essentially basically the time I
obelisks would have a huge role yeah so
I was like if it does build an air it
would look cool at least mmm-hmm know
kind of curious if they do any like
in-game visual representation besides
like a baby hologram
yes that's a good point this is I mean
the Bible's the portal thing was pretty
cool how do you feel about a community
event of this nature in general
I mean they're always cool I like there
is something in game so this is like the
first time cuz they tried to Mars one
being like hey you gotta go push back on
Mars like go do all these night falls
that go open all these resonant stems
and all this stuff
and yeah you can check Twitter and you
can see it but there's nothing in game
saying like hey you hover over Mars and
be like hey the community efforts that
like 75% or something like over well
I'll go run another one cuz we're
getting closer this one you get
literally log can be like where we at
how we do in how long is this thing
gonna take when we get this thing to
come out its February 4th the next
season comes out March 10th
we've got like five weeks in there so
all of those pieces are gonna be I like
how it's in game mmm and I guess we can
go through a couple of these bullets to
say contributing generates a 25% flat
progression to your time lost weapon
bounties so if you hold three time loss
weapon bounties and turn in 400 flector
Franklin are they done
yeah that's a good question that is a
very good question like hey I want a
farm weapon well I have five thousand to
turn in so perfect paradox perfect
paradox perfect paradox Bam Bam Bam Bam
three guns like is that how you read
that that's how it reads to me okay no I
was like I mean yeah like it seems like
you know you do you do your part with
that five thousand donation right you
know they're gonna not make you fork
your hard-earned frack the line without
providing some benefits though you can
either upgrade your residence rank which
I still don't know if I'm gonna why I
would put anything into the other Tower
obelisk or the other obelisk on other
planets where just to make those like
eleven or twelve or third I don't know
why you would take those any higher if I
can just like literally get free weapons
for putting it in the tower that's for
them so they're gonna have to explain
that a little bit more and again being
vague not always the good thing yeah
like if you're like hey if you have all
your all your obelisk up the rock right
fifteen when you log in the next week
you're gonna get like a thousand fractal
I need be like oh that's actually not so
bad
so mmm that type of stuff again a little
clarification hopefully we get four
would be nice to have 5,000 may sound
like a lot if you haven't been playing
but I mean I've been pretty casual I
really have like finished my obelisk
just like now you have the st. daily
bounties that's 200 and day you have
your weekly is on each character you
know that's 800 even if you've been
doing it fairly slow like you needed
8800 for all the for planetary obelisks
yes but then on top of that you need to
5,000 most you need 13,800 during a
total grand for every Tower obelisk and
then or every obelisk and then the
emblem would be 13,800 yeah I think I
think that's and I think I'm what really
helps is when you upgrade a lot of these
obelisks that really actually give you
bonus fractal line in other activities
by playing you know gambit while playing
you know sundial while playing crucible
you would you have those random
increased chances to get a drop you know
so that and then you couple that with
that um that consumable that they have
at the tower right yeah I'll pick it up
and
no different activities give it to you
you know saying stuff like that so you
know if you play and again I've been
saying like you like no in an hour
semi-casual this season and I've got you
know close to 5,000 already and he goes
to show you if long as you upgrade those
obelisks and you unlock those bonus
track the line segments you should be
fine you got a good video out on that by
the way oh thanks watch your video that
looks good
but yeah I mean even haven't granted for
Python yet so I know I'm gonna get a
thumb in there oh yeah I'll be living in
there yeah so overall it seems like it
may sound like a big number at the start
but as much as we've been playing I mean
go play your sundial a couple times
you'll get a few in there you get ten
for every run at the end of like your
week you get a new no just a lot of
places for it
mm-hmm I really see a point good Oh hold
on let me read the combined total of the
planets increase the residency power if
you have them all 11 your tower isn't
its 4646 thunder will be the free
freckling you get every week do mmm but
we meetin
600 a week yeah which was big and I'm
gonna say my guy all my obelisks at
level 11 yes I know yeah you're talking
about that's right now yeah I remember
seeing that number I just haven't looked
at it since I max them all out and
everything but then ions right so well
yeah if that's the amount of fractal
line you get then that's huge actually
show hmm but I would say once you get
them all up you don't need to go still
dump more in there it does get more
efficient to probably go like if you're
looking for weapon rolls just literally
pull a couple bounties donate enough to
the tower knock ya out like that not
much once you get up to 11 cuz ya
getting 5,000 a week would be crazy but
yes that's the way that works that's
gonna give you all the weapon rolls
you'll ever need and maybe and that
actually might make more sense with what
Prescott is saying as we go through
these stages if we're able to donate
that much per hour week plus whatever
you get in-game then these numbers start
seeing a little more reasonable yes I
agree I agree it was a little daunting
at first I'm not even though the
community is huge you know I was like
what if I was not playing like how's
that you know so yeah that's a good
point I think I think it's gonna be a
combination of that and that that weekly
stack that you get based on you know the
levels of tower residents of your
obelisk stuff like that
[Music]
but what do you think the emblem by the
way somebody had a funny thing out there
I think it was Python uh reveal on
Twitter you eyes and then the long
emblem underneath like the curve it
looks like kind of a smirking smile
almost like a Cheshire Cat kind of
smiled yes the Cheshire Cat battle
ensued that was like really you kind of
break me here but yeah it's got a cool I
mean so unique animals kind of got that
like I don't want to say fractal line
look to it but it's got like the yeah I
you know almost magic I shimmery kind of
a little bit yeah so I'm cool with that
it seems coat it seems unique I know we
get a emblem in the emblem and a shader
for doing all this 5,000 but bigger
event that happens will be when it's
finished so we'll get the lumen later
mm-hmm
they have been tweeting out guys if you
haven't been following like Bungie
stores Twitter and stuff follow them
they've been doing some tweets about
giveaways and things like that there's a
lot of lore books on the store stuff on
all that definitely follow them
just a reminder
the Guardians for Australia they are
still doing that t-shirt as well for a
little while I think it goes through
like mid-february if you haven't got
your chance to get into one of those
it's a cool-looking t-shirt I'm like
mm-hmm it's literally like spaceship
sitting on kangaroo just like it just
looks cool I love the like who designed
that shirt did an awesome job
mm-hmm but overall I don't think there's
that much else somebody like actually
believes that Mount
my god listen mean all those times a
minute sir it's ndh stuff is hard man
let's get toy a good luck going to
Bungie then my god like he's having
trouble not saying something that people
already have out on the internet much
less the stuff that's out there listen G
you can invite me anytime don't you
don't you listen to him I can keep that
live your life the last no I won't throw
away the key yeah yes hurry up
[Laughter]
but it just seemed like a somewhat quiet
week right very quiet I was actually
surprised how quiet this 12 was I was it
was very very very lacks yeah
tell me help we covered most of what's
going on with the week in about 45
minutes in about 45 minutes like it's
weird yeah yeah like so do you think
this Imperium foundation is gonna be
what carries us to the end of the season
is this do you think like kind of our
last bit do you think there's anything
else in those final three weeks after
crimson days I don't I remember them
saying don't quote me on this but I
thought I remember them saying there are
no more or someone saying there are no
more secret exotics or exotic quest
brother season
so
Bob I'm getting look right now it is
January 31st right yep and we're
February from what I understand the
season Oh season of the redacted um will
be most likely March tenth or something
like yeah days in the recent past I'll
tell you it's March 10th March - okay so
that's basically you know we're tied at
Lisa's fabric so this is like a month
right so we got crimson days in there I
think this is gonna be this all gung-ho
community effort for a month I really do
I didn't kill for him I I don't I can't
see I mean I would like so no I can't
see it you know I I just I dig that day
they're gonna you know they're doing
this with the levels and if we get you
know if we get 5,000 subscribers we got
5 million subscribers you're gonna get
this and then you get 10 it's like it's
creating fake engagement to act like
we're doing something let's just call it
what it is you know say and I get it I'm
not knocking the hustle this guy got
nothing left for this season you know
Sam we know it wasn't no dungeon we out
respect your trickery this time you
riches as long as you respect us with
good lord and from what I heard your
respect enough so you know I know what
this this is the shell game this is the
hustle let's try to keep them engaged at
all that Ferrari as much as we can Wow
until we get it for order come on you
don't run a base like this why come on
do tell you guys [ __ ]
it's the same bounties we're gonna be
doing from the obelisks we're gonna be
literally doing the same they kill 5300
cabal you know 5300 cabal scale 6 times
falling captain's go to this planet
shoot this guy do it what we've been
doing
there's nothing I mean unless there's
some new development there's nothing
else I anticipate that's going to be new
you know I'm saying so you're so five
weeks of fractal I'm farming
end-of-season transition whatever big
moment is he's enough mmm what about the
season 10 nothing right never yeah
mm-hmm it was a nut
it was undying 9 is this for dawn so I
think 10 that sound sounds awful it'll
feel like they never were on the right
track like 8 should have been opulences
like the end of Brighton year but it
wasn't like this but it wasn't any weird
mm-hmm yeah this what I anticipate I
mean again they just got to finish it
narrative Lee well I knew what I was
getting into I'm not really upset
because I I don't mind this particular
grind oh [ __ ] oh by the army already
[ __ ] away God we will send your availa
tragic lizard this is what let this is
what your $10 is getting you people
remember this is $10 this is not $30
this is not shadow keep this is 10 bucks
if you think they're gonna have us doing
you know some fly new missions and I
don't see it I don't see it all I expect
is just some nice st. lure some nice
Osiris we want to see how this
transitions into the next season you
know long as that's done narrative Lee
well maybe sneak a cinema in there wrap
it up and then they can you know hit us
with the front ring you guys did it
you amassed 16 million you owe and for
now you're gonna get two emblems and
you're gonna do this and we know the
fraud or yeah just get us to the season
and what I wanna talk about during but
it's good for its it's understandable
for
it's it's I get it you got nothing's
like your man you ever have a friend and
you know he's just not doing well
financially right now you just like look
I understand you have big ideas you
throw he's gonna take us to Outback you
thought you're gonna do all these cool
fly restaurants or whatever but we go
into the dollar menu we're going to
McDonald's today because that's what the
budget allows that's where we at right
now the budget is allowing us to be on
the value meal but right now next season
yeah we might step up the Outback we
might step up to the steakhouse we might
do some fly next take it our we're
taking our lady out we're going to
Applebee's we're eggs next row we might
go to have easi by going so Chili's
Chili's Chili's is up there now come on
that's not wrong it's gonna be a while
before we go to those cool spots and I'm
okay with that
last last easy so hold on let me see if
I can translate this so yes destiny
three if that ever happens that's like
the trim to Ruth's Chris that's a person
yes crazy time you
mmm-hmm then you have expansions - those
are stepping down - mmm salt grass
you've got like your steak house yes
okay get some dessert I mean they got a
decent wine pairing in there but not a
massive selection not like a book of a
wine menu then we take him down - so
that was like your September expansions
like shadow keep then now that's a leap
if you go from like salt grass to like
the Mickey D's drive-through or are we
like the Applebee's sirloin that's like
shoe leather like where we at Road you
know about what we'll season of all done
oh this is cuz it is like you wanna say
like hey like the way you've described
this season you're like hey I don't have
a raid I don't have a dungeon I've
actually been having a lot of fun this
season so yeah you hit a lot of crap I'm
giving it be like you know what this is
this is the popeyes chicken sandwich
like it's all this height but it's still
just the five hours chickens it's not
this great
Oh spigots wow this is better than I
thought it was gonna be right that's
what this is the Popeye chicken sandwich
one this what is it it's really not no
fine dining
it was just packaged nice it impressed
us more in a cardboard clamshell yeah
you got put it up the restaurant with
the big with the lapel and you serve it
to you like they put that chicken
sandwich or some fine tablecloth and
they put out the good so big this is a
classic segment this is a classic
glassware it's a great by the way it's
that friend you know he's not doing well
this month you go with a family house
and that's all I got to serve you but
they served it to you in the best of
best l utensil their best plates you
know it's like I think Ruth's Chris is a
little high for d3 yeah I don't know how
to stagger them yeah somewhere there's
an Applebee's sirloin in there and
that's like your season The Drifter
where you like I got more fun but it's
like burnt to a crisp and it's over like
yeah it was bad jephta that's easy -
Jeff - steak man it was like shoe
leather
oh yeah well done have you - this thing
- style shoe leather right there what's
the hardest thing wraps up yes sir well
I'm just gonna making you hold on as
possible
[Laughter]
for everybody out there this is the fair
warning
this is gonna be spoiler talk
data-mining heads up now their YouTube
videos that may have tripped into your
Twitter and YouTube feed and you may
hear about this already if you don't
want to know what is coming for the next
season now is your time to tune out we
thank you guys for tuning in I am e
Bonta CBO and T is on Twitter YouTube
twitch and all those fun things we run
out for where they can find you make it
like 10 seconds at Lord Candido and home
Iowa podcast YouTube and Lords of gaming
that let you could check me out while we
talk about so we're gonna give you guys
five seconds if you guys don't hear
anything about what potential husband
farm scene popped up all these different
places or otherwise we are gonna get
into it in five plenty of warning here
so if you don't hear it it's your fault
for this you're still out yes is still
easier you want to hear than three you
guys are still in chat you don't hear
spoilers there isn't it there's no
coming back everything goes to spoilers
so this is your end of your episode two
and then my final pinky finger to you
right here this is it fancy teacup and
to fit unleash there no more food talk I
feel like I let go I feel like you got
something you got to get off your chest
ah you don't what I am so happy that I
am worthy to talk about the next subject
let's get it man so the prophecy is true
it has come to this day the day that
I've waited so long so patiently there's
been so many last word podcasts that I
have [ __ ] didn't complain that I have
been my head's been in the ground in PvP
community dammit this is our day it is
official every star every dot every
everything has aligned and um man this
is a great day so shout out to our man
what's our what's our man named gin sore
right a man gin sore so with that latest
patch update there's been on some data
mining and
yeah man so it looks like uh Iberian
foundation is leading to something you
know said and then basically we talked
about the data mining of the of the
fracture line and and what its gonna do
and part of that restoration will be
restoring trials trials of Osiris that
trouser of the one chicks I would say
we're starting the lighthouse sure over
store in the lighthouse really say that
yes it does shout out to my man jinsol
okay this is what they pull from this is
the exact sentence they pull from the
data man with the restoration of the
lighthouse complete trials of Osiris has
returned Bobby you know say he's back
and more will return and we got the name
of the new season in season of the
worthy let's get it so it is official
this is what they've been strolling us
with with popeyes chicken sandwiches in
Orleans like food for this you know we
knew this was coming shout out to all
the people was it uh fruiting these guys
and it was a true fan guard all those
guys we knew who our trials veterans
guys that we knew do nothing but PvP
some guys that don't even play destiny
anymore that they flew out and we were
told it's not for the season of dawn cuz
we all been we got all hype for season
adoring like y'all this might be the one
but this is the predecessor so that's
why again I have been patient I've been
cool because I knew that this day would
happen it just feels good to be
vindicated only probably person that
said it besides me was Paulette ashy so
I gotta get a C credit but I was on this
I told you I was coming I told y'all I
told y'all so this is my moment I'm very
excited but I wanted to say this you
know at the end of the day you know I'm
not gonna act like just because trials
comes back destiny is safe no but I will
say that it is such a shot in the arm
for the PDP Kamui which we know those
numbers are down regular population
numbers are still high PvE all the other
stuff that still solid you know man but
now it's like boom
here comes the pvp thing so I want to
see how they handle it I want to also
see because we know it can't be a PvP
only season right they're not gonna do a
season in the drift that it's going to
be a PvE activity so now that you hear
that and now that you've got the
information cuz you the one that broke
it to be in a text I was like what place
the date of mine okay let me see okay I
want to know what you thought when you
heard the news and everything that broke
there was a split second when I saw
season of the worthy I thought somehow
that actually was related to like
opulence and callous or something like
that being part of it he just literally
for half a second yeah mate but I was
like kind of went away when I figured
out anymore but there was a tease of
mine because I was like he's still
sitting out there I was like where we
gonna go season of the worthy and then
season of like the unworthy as we go
into like season and like our death or
something but the stuff that we got in
quarters of time because something's
gonna kill us
mm-hm I was trying to see if there was a
leap there in my head then I started to
see more of like this thing on screen
about a as you rebuild this thing and it
makes the lighthouse and we're gonna get
these activities back I was like okay
I haven't actually thought that deep on
per say a lake
trials coming back cool hmm it's been
building eliminations been there we know
they've been working on it taking
feedback right but I can honestly like
count it takes more fingers than one
hand at least to be like pretty major
people like dude PvP is broken I'm tired
of it or it's like you work on these
certain things and depending on the
quest and stuff I know the met is never
perfect mm-hmm 100% no it's not and I'm
aware of that but on the other side
I am honestly still wondering if the
rose-colored glasses of trials we know
I'm this is a legitimate thing because I
want trials to succeed I want PvP to
have like an in-game grind to go for and
I know there's always gonna be DDoS or
so it's always gonna be people like
using the heavy metal weapons and just
like the cheapest stuff they can go in
for their trials card have you seen the
bad habits buddy gin them lately they
have but there's always gonna be more
there's more people to figure it out so
I don't mean to say that I was like I
don't want it to be successful I am just
hoping that they do pull off a good
launch a somewhat clean activity as much
anti-cheat as they can in there so
people who do have like this high bar in
their mind from d1 and you've got people
that come in like you take some of the
big streamers the craft ease the Lupus
who used to do this who are so much
bigger now if they start streaming and
they're getting like stream sniped or if
they're getting cheated on or if they're
getting ddosed while they're doing these
things I mean I think everybody's
probably gonna need a VPN maybe Bungie
has like a pairing with Nord VPN in the
background but Blair is rabia mm-hmm all
of those things
I'm just hoping it goes smooth enough
that it can successfully build something
back into the game that's been missing I
don't want like the state of cheating in
the state of ddossing and PC making
ddossing that much easier and steam that
and stuff not hiding your all of that
stuff I don't want it to take away
because when PC makes it even more and I
know a decent chunk of the population is
on PC as well yeah so that's where I
worry about cheating hacks emboss all
those things mm-hmm that's just my worry
no I get it I guess this is where I
struggle with the guys who say I don't
know if it should come back because of
the cheating and because of and people
that say Oh rose-colored glasses and you
know let's not forget you know when d1
and Trials was at its height right
the meta was probably the most horrible
we had old school born we had icebreaker
we had all these one-hit-kill
back then the medes of d1 let's not
forget we're like every meta was like
only two weapons were on top yeah a
matter of like the vex you had the
matter of the syrups regime you have the
matter of rocket launchers like truth in
Gjallarhorn or glitter raining squads
right so it just makes me laugh when
people go you know it's you can't bring
it back because it has to be you know
say now I get your point on the sheet
I'm gonna get to that part but as far as
the meta is concerned I don't want to
hear it because at the end of the day in
my opinon
played as pvp and i've said it since d2
has come along outside of when they had
that horrible launch when they thought
it was cute to bring double primaries
and and that slow plodding 4v4 garbage
of trials of the nine you don't say it
was trashed and it wasn't even
elimination right so all you gotta do is
you bring back elimination which they've
been battling right 3v3
elimination you have trial specific Maps
there are only certain Maps like you
know burning shrine those classic 3v3
tight you know I'm saying Maps you have
those in play right now as far as the
meta you have to admit II playing for
the times that you do play PvP how many
times are you sitting there screaming at
the screen that from a gun perspective
that you got killed by this one gun not
in d 2v2 you can name about six to eight
dogs you my goddamn beloved damn oh this
guy hit me with you know outbreak oh oh
man this guy hit me with this Scout or
whatever whatever it's it's always a
very of course it's gonna be the shotgun
apes here and there but sidearms are in
a better place in PvP right now you know
shotguns are fusions right now air until
the vote boys the vote gang boot gangs
out here
as our air until the sniper right now
the exact problem is in rebuke right so
what I'm saying is there's enough and
every archetype of weapon to be dominant
that's a good matter that's what people
people to realize it's a better man and
I make the other it's a better matter
now D to then D one was now where the
issue I have and this is a Bungie
problem is of course cheating right of
course this is where I'm with you 1,000%
she practices gotta be I mean it has to
be heightened you can't be letting
people do dodge you can't be letting
dudes run wild you can't be doing the
fake carrying and the fake cards know
that I'm rich doing it they have to know
this coming in they have to know that it
you don't say
now unfortunately they're at the mercy
of peer to peer that's nothing we can do
about that aspect the only thing I would
say is you kind of got a velvet rope it
you know I'm saying you had I feel when
trials come back it cannot be a free
activity sorry no it be able to say
gotta give the cops on you can buy the
season pass all occurred so that's
actually weird for them to say hey if
you want to play trial then bug won but
part of the season you trials debuted in
this season you know I'm saying yeah so
you need to have that season you got to
pay you got to pay so all I'm saying is
that's the first little wall it's not
gonna stop everybody but that's a big
one because if you put it for you to
play now you open it up the masses on PC
to get but you put that judge you know
there so that's it I mean other than
that you know it the key to me you know
to me I'm not even scared about another
stuff most people are scared of you know
what I'm scared of the rewards yeah the
rewards have to be good because if you
do all this right this is the problem
with destiny too right now they have
these great activities it's old backed
evenings and then at the annual like
brah I did all this for this nah so you
you got yet drag you can we scream i'm
corey skinning if it's if it's classic
vintage stuff that people want you know
it has to be
the trials of Osiris stuff it has to be
cool looking again bring our Egyptian
themes back bring all that I would like
say 14 to be the announcer you know I'm
saying I think that would be a cool
funny take him talking rushing and
getting your laughing and you know I'm
saying we imagine like give brother
Vance a roll please
let's get his voice actor in here
earlier Vance know that Osiris is there
it's like oh yeah at some point I will
be got the shaft of light years bring
back this what they gotta do they gotta
bring back literally how it was towards
the end where you have your trials
bounties you have to give something to
the casual now you can't make it team
sweat and they don't get nothing to play
for so remember the trials bounties
would say hey just play this amount of
marches get these amount of kills and
you still got a chance
you may not get the Adept version right
but you still got a chance
also you know um lot put maybe put some
exotics and stuff don't don't weapons
gotta be cool the armors gotta be cool
everything is down if you put those
rewards to powerful yet cool-looking
rewards you will get the community
that's all you got the one thing about
destiny players when those videos come
out and it's a cool gun and it's a cool
thing and you hear all you all you know
when you know what you did a good job
when you hear ask the crowd say oh it's
nasty boys well you hear him saying
always nasty boy when you hear fallout
plays jump out and say you know if you
want to be a crucible King you gotta you
hear those voices that's when they
nailed it that's all you gotta do it's a
simple simple just nail that any got it
yeah I'm saying I'm gonna shout to say
creeps over 2.0 d2 trials well we would
all they don't bro I will live in the
ever verse store if they put in
ornaments we're DS D would trials
there's money you can spend next season
throws money at spring I'll play the
harlot straight behind I'll play for the
whole set give me the Warlock with the
Anubis head with the Allman Rasul man
somebody comes very long
to catch any stream and be like why is
that reverse they sold out so literally
Tori left everything has been bought man
I will employ the entire Bungie staff
off of my income for me by every foolish
all Cyrus armor come on how cool it was
with the chroma nobody do you okay so a
couple questions now I want to get your
opinion on these as we go through is
your the big trials King first let's go
you don't want new armor you want old
armor not that I don't want new armor
but it has to be aesthetically steamed
like Osiris like the Egyptian God that
he is it I don't want again if I see
that blue white you know what I'm
talking about that that that big face
ship is anywhere near this I am going to
petition Bungie I don't want to see the
big face girl we had her enough of her
Cesar to draft to let her have our
conversations with him we're done with
you you have been removed Osiris is the
wave that's what we follow right so give
me the cookies the coolest-looking
warlock ever the circle give me just
give me something with the I the little
eyeball Oh make sure you make sure you
have some shirts cuz I'm buying all the
Bungie structures yeah I better have
trials shirts and gear I'm gonna have
everything in that Bungie store Bungie
I'm tell if you want to take my money
make everything in the Bungie store
trials themed I am buying it all I'm
telling you and I'm short up to gcx
right what's that what's up god oh okay
so I'm encouraging you think yes it's
like my interview with you so you just
get to spill everything today
let's go so we've got st. 14 in the
tower with some of the drapery and
banners and stuff or trials you see the
hints you seen Osiris is at the sundial
which is leaving yeah that's a good
point I don't know who's running what
where people can end up after the season
I think the way to do it is empyrion is
gonna rebuild the lighthouse right
bring the lighthouse back to the
old-school lighthouse I think because of
the nature of Osiris and he they like to
call him the wild Osiris is gonna
probably be in the infinite doing what
he do you know say it would be nice if
he's a permanent NPC but I don't get the
sense Osiris as a guy that likes to stay
in one place so where he's a vagabond
he's a rumor you could say he's a
vagabond oh he's got to see the sights
photo was it know what he said no he
said the problem is d1 trials only
PlayStation Xbox it's only the problem
was DDoS now PC to brew you can't get
away from me there's no magical
situation where I feel you there's just
no magical situation that we're gonna
you know we're not talking dedicated
servers PC unfortunately even though
people don't like it it's the biggest
base that's where people are playing
that's T right now they just gotta be on
the ball with the anti-cheating stuff
they gotta be extremely sensitive to it
that's it that's all you can do cheating
is going to have it we cannot act like
it's not but anyway back to your
question so you as you could tell been
waiting all week long no butt hole we
humpin literally and ready a bit okay so
it's what you do
I would love all stars to be the
permanent you see I don't think it's
gonna happen st. is probably gonna be
there this is where you can hit and
let's say no remember st. was given
Shaq's the bet he already set us up
say st. oh shucks you've just given
these weapons away where's the blood
sweat tears so he's gonna set a new
standard you know and he's already
rocking Osiris kind of stuff he got the
flag in there that's my boy right there
everything is through Saint let him do
the commentary I say you still got to
keep Vance around old Vance has to have
a function he's a regular NPC he's just
sits on mercury doing his flashpoint
thing he doesn't have too much going on
besides just there and I think he's
maybe maybe
you gotta do it's gotta be those two I
just don't know how to implement I don't
want to fly to mercury every time I want
to play trials
what you gonna plan it well I don't want
to go very well either from the director
I don't want to go talk to brother vain
all agree to go to him to do that how
you gonna get your bounties though you
got it but we gotta make up your bodies
okay let me get my damn let me give my
bodies from the screen that just
eventually I'm hoping comes you're like
September yes everything but that's like
I'm gonna go on power tower tower like
every third thing that I do st. will be
the one who should be like basically
running it honestly man there's all that
type of stuff I just wanna know what is
gonna happen poor brother vids what's
gonna happen to a bit stake taking his
job man I'm trying to pull for you from
the vans but say now here take your job
I don't know what's gonna happen with
that voice actor
oh no maybe they cutting him anybody
gonna say get killed let's just deed
nobody just knows that there's a
synthesizer in there and he's like you
know following the warlock ways so it
would make them but I feel definitely
see you gotta have safe as the announcer
how funny happy that would be pretty
cool seems like he would have a fitting
voice from what we saw I could see that
being good I do I do this I am gonna
miss shacks saying it though it was cool
and shacks it said trials of Osiris but
if I always thought maybe maybe he's
still the innocent it's like a crucible
maybe just like Saints your bounty guy
sitting in the crucible directory page
going to trials and it's gonna he's
still announced by Shaq's mmm see we'll
see I'm very curious to see how to here
I think they can't though because much
as I love checks you have to they have
to do it like I did a iron bed remember
when Saladin debuted that was kind of
cool I was kind of cool yeah you have to
give trials its own flavor it has to
have a distinct voice and this is trials
3.0 baby you got a you got to put all
the window dressing all you got to put
the frosting you got a you got to make
that thing real nice man
sinister what you mean now who do you
want now you don't want you don't want
um you got titanate that's what you're
too much tight your hand you blood
listen Saint is family and you gotta let
st. Roch that let him do the voice let
him do the voice
I mean look I wouldn't be ban my matter
if it's on Cyrus hey you talk a Gitto Oh
Cyrus and those commenting on it from
the infinite forest be like only thing
my stars and I'll have the abyss by man
but he's a bit of an intellectual snob
so I don't know if I really want him
commenting on PvP you know zan like he's
not really a dude that's gonna get you
height to fight Saint is gonna get you
well actually of course a [ __ ] but
actually it's not really it sinister but
if I got say my vote is on Saint let st.
do this those two and let let no Cyrus
do his Osiris thing I wish you next
question let's go
the card
oh do you have opinions on how old work
use it going through multiple cards
matchmaking once you've got you one like
if you make it to the lighthouse should
you ever be hearing with people who are
trying their first attempt on a card
oh no matchmaking sir oh no match making
sure that is that true oh yeah I've
never messed you up right now that would
get you angry down mm-hmm no no no that
that's how we have to do this we have to
no no match making you gonna have to get
with some friends it's only three so you
had to get with some friends and you
gonna have to commit oh okay so I if
that's button if and that's still gonna
be a complete wrench that you'll have to
see if that actually holds well give you
that caveat for now I'm talking about
the system pairing people into matches
themselves oh you're my shield to
skill-based anger against skills versus
like is it the trials card like hey if
you've got five wins your parent people
against not five wins if you've got no
are you playing people more in that
upper echelon even if you're starting a
new card but you've got nine wins that
weekend
kind of got to grow that that's how it
used to be it would be it would be okay
the nine stacks versus the nine you know
to eight stacks versus the eight stacks
you know as always as close to that
ratio as they prefer some what if
somebody finished those four nights that
gets a new card and they're like hey I'm
gonna go to people on a fresh card are
gonna go run this brand new guy through
but they've already finished 14 cards
that weekend
well you go ahead to skill base
matchmaking you sir okay if we're gonna
look at sure it's not me by the way I'm
on the logo I don't know who's being
dragged we just gonna have to eat alone
yourself and look I know this is a big
thing to community right now a shout out
to all my boy khakis I know he's on the
other side I know half the communities
on the other side no one's probably
gonna agree where I'm gonna say but look
skill-based matchmaking has to exist
yeah it has to exist you know I get it
you know if you don't want skills based
matchmaking get your behind out of a
sweaty competitive match and play casual
there's no fee our casual get getting
the casual queue and go do it up for fun
but the duels out here that's really
trying to get this because everything is
sweating I'm mad that I'm stopping
people and now they're putting up
against people had all sorts topping
this is not right that I'm facing people
on my level like waiting dude at it I'm
not from that I'm sorry
no disrespect to no content I'm from
shield I know it stop still sharp of
steel but that's what it is like if you
want a five card you gonna play somebody
else with a five card if you're a low is
that good then you should be playing
people have equal of what is so wrong
with that I just don't understand this
that in the Destiny community is the
only community that does not want
competitive PvP balance they like no I
must stop with my friends so I can feel
good like what listen again I don't have
no problem if it's a casual playlist you
know I'm saying but if it's competitive
huh we got we got we got Bloods in the
sand man we gotta fight for this you got
to do that so yeah that's that's where
I'm at with that whole thing and it's
gotta be in trials I mean you have to
you can't how cuz dudes are gonna do
exactly what you said they gonna dig on
get that dad that drink go to my house
let me grab two new noobs and think that
that's gonna bring a eel or whatever it
is down and then they gonna pop star
back No so that's my man
season of the worthy trials is part of
it end of the season
it leaves seasonal activities they only
stay so long the track this ain't season
that this this is the shebang this is
this is what we do
this is the new dungeon right so that we
ain't leavin when a dungeon came they
say you know all right here lick his
let's take back our pit of heresy
brother we are pinnacle pinnacle stay
and remember we're only a weekend
activity that's the other thing
remember we go from Friday to Monday and
then we bounce yeah I could have the
rest of it what it is yours just flying
with sir
why doesn't zoom run this damn thing
he's got the same travel schedule yeah
Shawn slow-mo here the only comedian
must I remind you that dogs are few slow
I don't know I don't know why people are
built like that but I don't know loco
what's going on brother um hold on nut
nut he said will you be able to get to
see grind for endgame stuff like 1994 do
you think its legs do you think you're
gonna be he's saying like the shards
like in-game material stuff like that or
is it gonna work like a raid you want it
won't run it once for the week and then
you're literally just doing it for fun
are the rewards gonna be something you
can did you sleep I get to the
lighthouse again do I get a chance in
another world on a gun in that weekend
or do I only get my one run per yeah
it's gotta be for the week it's got to
be raged and especially because people
were sitting there they're living there
and then what they'll do is they'll get
the whole loop pool they liked two weeks
is a good that's the part of the hustle
we know part of the hustle is to make
you come back so the key to me the key
is not um skill base my frame
she is not Metta the key is not any of
that except two things
yes it's a cheating has to be on
heightened but the real key is be wards
rework because if these rewards they
could have everything present nature was
a trash
it's gonna flood that's where that's the
only thing I fear but I know if they've
been working this long and let's be wide
you got the best artists in the game
they got the best designers again shout
the nine hydras you know I'm saying like
they got the best when it comes to set
pieces weapons and all that and even if
they don't design something they are
sitting on so many amazing assets from
trials path that they can bring back
could you imagine if doctor in the past
and came back because they could you
imagine if do you think it would even be
as good as it was though yeah
what'd you call it it's basically still
further repeated Peter you know I'm
saying but with a better you know a
little better aim-assist and whatever
whatever you know could you imagine if
they brought me but trials also debuted
I doubt they do it because I think they
said they permanently will go away from
kinetic element to weapons I remember
trials had debuted that at one point
remember I doubt they'd cuz I don't
think they I don't think they like that
for nightfall they don't like us ready
to be have it all is different very I
forbid to have options god it's annoying
I know you go how they don't like us do
melting their content so I doubt that's
gonna happen but I think also what would
be cool which would be a trials first
they need a trials exotic
they've never had that like a trial
specific exact I don't know how you
would get it yeah I don't know how that
would play maybe it's just a ring maybe
it's the one thousand voices of trials
of the lighthouse box and instead of
reading them yeah maybe they do it that
way they love to do they random you know
whatever pinnacle thing but you've got
to have a cool cool weapon set that
rotates and you got to have the cool
armor and all that stuff man that would
be okay armor yes from the box at the
Lighthouse and hmm ever verse comes in
stack in like Egyptian ornaments and
everything is only a neveress the box is
like trash military armor
yeah what are you all I'm what do you
think what if it what if that's where
the good-looking stuff falls is into
ever verse not erna below through trials
oh that this could happen this is a
realistic thing that they could do it's
the question best thing I could get
upset
III am nervous ever versus moving very
she's Tess's movers strong out here it
needs these dusty streets she's very
strong she has very powerful allies and
what she gets she gets what she wants so
um yeah I am concerned I do feel you
have to do what they did though which is
you have to have two sets of armor which
is remember the trials bounties guys
remember old school they would have a
specific it was kind of like the Walmart
trials gear like it was man for libel
you had the Pharaoh diamond raw stuff
that you've got from actually you got
the boots you got to take that home and
it's so cool what walks behind you in
his Egyptian full mask like for the
homies like yeah it's like the numbers
walks in you're like
life is lost I need that Anubis man and
I need the woman at all and I'd be that
kid so bad so far but oh yeah so there's
gotta be some Walmart here for the for
the casuals you know you got to give
them some lesser versions of weapon
because that's the thing if you just
make it so sweaty the the casuals are
gonna tap out right
they're never gonna go to the lighthouse
let's be honest it was very low right
but a guy like me listen I'm a full
disclosure I've only been to the
lighthouse twice ever right so but what
the encouraging thing for me was again
doing those bounties and that last big
bounty you had the chance based on all
the play time it was on man and I got my
first doctrine of passing not the Adept
version you know I'm saying and I was
like yo this is cool bro this is cool it
gave me inspired me to keep playing
because it is demoralized
it's a sweaty activity you get bumped
out you get that second loss oh we gotta
bring our booms ballet I was getting
there and boons we gotta bring on
Mercy's back we got it has to retain
this the chance it is a hard thing to
win nine straight not everybody out here
is true Vanguard and fruiting all them
dudes you know say it's a hard thing so
you got to give us the mistake you know
the the hit you know that here's the
mess up kind of thing shout to drag it
twice you know I'm saying no wins it's a
lot it is it is a lot it is a lot
there's no doubt circulatory should be
eight seven seven and two even what it
is it was the perfect formula when it
was done right listen I don't like that
it's nine cuz I'm it's hard for me but
at the end of the day it inspired me to
get better it inspired me to keep
playing if we put the entry down easier
you know how destiny does when they make
things too easy and then everybody gets
it and then everybody's done you still
got to make people try hard a bit in
there and that's why I said if the gear
is amazing and you have that feeling
like I had I'll never forget a warlock
rolled up in the tower that Egyptian
gets gobbled him all the way around a
tower I hit the inspect button the hell
is this
so I got to play this trials thing I
don't even know what it is all right I
am playing this is a myth that's what
you need and that's how that's how it
gets to I guess the ball roller so yeah
man you got to bring it back
all right the trials armor well where
does this fall in the stat and armor 2.0
category is it in the trash dumpster
brah like your pinnacles half the time
or is it gotta be I mean do you think
it's gonna be like hey if this is is
your good stat roll from the right brah
there's got to be 16 up got to be you
got I mean especially man nothing warm
are you not the warm heart it might be
there but no it's not I know they gotta
work on that
they can't it's got it you tell them
people to win nine times flawless like
all right dude me yeah me not you I'm
wasn't coming at you per se I'm just
talking about you know going on that
Bungie theoretically but of like that's
gonna do is to go nine times and do this
crazy thing while battling DDoS is and
I'm battling you know anti quit people
man it's got to God to have and you got
to also allow shots earnest is gonna
know you gotta allow that feature that
if your friend gets bumped
he can come back in because that used to
suck there's nothing more demoralizing
then your friend has a legit disconnect
and then it's a 2v3
for the whole joint like come on you
know saying baguette no like for any
honestly any cop match mmm I get so
tired
somebody disc it getting disconnected if
cheating is an issue mm-hmm like either
that matches null and void if somebody
drops or you can't like lose progress or
take the Dane for a loss whatever it is
when it comes to that like point where
you are down a man the system you'd be
like it's three versus two - it's been
three versus two for multiple not like
thirty seconds in a pot back in its
mobile rivets it has to register
something that says yes this doesn't
count against you anymore because you
are in a complete disadvantage of a body
mm-hmm now in if you win it cool you get
the benefits people pulling out one
VIII's awesome Congrats good job mm-hmm
but for most of who are trying to get
through to sweaty as it's gonna be you
can't make it to where you lose a person
and by crap of connection internet
ddossing whatever it may be but you get
dinged for truly fighting like half a
fight for 2/3 of advantage like I agree
now if it's like the last round and
somebody drops ya then come on you know
I'm saying you made it that far but it's
like there's gotta be a point where it's
early enough on it's gonna mix early
yeah like the first two round it should
be like one of the first two rounds yeah
if that happens there should be an
algorithm that says look we cannot
penalize them to the extent of the law
on this you know I'm saying there needs
to be something in place with all even
if you're not gonna do that you got to
give that person a drop or something you
got to do something you cannot a lot of
a shout out to um Artie I believe yeah
you could join back in Cobb now they do
have it in comp I have seen it I've
experienced it myself firsthand where
something happened I got bumped and then
I was able to get back in you know
saying with no problem but you know that
that's the one thing that definitely
definitely has to happen yeah I mean
look man I'm excited bro at the end of
the day I don't know what it is to be
like Frye
was so special cuz you had sir well the
desert came around it new trials up and
you ran over to the you know said to the
was the the evoking plan whatever we
distinguished or without whatever we
used to do what we used to do and now
hopefully it's mercury you know I'm
saying we'll see where we got a duty to
go get it
I don't you know that the foundation is
there you can't really mess it up too
much you know it's just like I said
rewards you know anti-cheating on fleek
as much as you possibly can and um yeah
let's kill this thing man cuz you guess
sitting on it sitting on some special
and if the community if listen I got
confidence they got some heavy hitters
at this at the at Bungie Stewie that
means let's do keep it in perspective to
think are many seasons trials has been
delayed
oh and we haven't had brows since Wayne
like it's bit can we say it's been a
full year to year they've been working
on us yeah like it so there's no way in
my opinion did you sat on something this
long right they care about it I showed
me one that they care about it enough to
say you know what this gotta be done
right they brought in the right people
I'm confident man
they're gonna knock this thing out the
only issue I'm worried about is reward
and aesthetics make it cool make it
worth us doing this I know you guys are
gonna knock it out with the play mode
and the fun just do the right thing with
the rewards and that's it you got it man
you got a winner and not half of the
community is satisfied and then back to
your half we know there has to be
something for you guys
this cannot be a PvP only season yes
that so I think everyone off he'll know
maybe we already see what happened to
Season Of The Drifter you know they try
to force us in the gambit for a whole
season mm-hmm oh yeah The Reckoning
reckoning yes they better not do no crap
like that neither where they force you
to play one to do the other they better
not do that
remember that foolishness oh if you do
you want the prime armor there is
infinite loop yeah don't die they do
Luke said it himself that was dumb like
they knew they'd drop the ball with that
they better not be linking trials and
nothing else the trials its own thing
let whatever's going on we need to be
worthy for be worthy for salute to the
Sun Dial it was cute it was cool we got
what we got I got my god rules for the
most part I got my extra perk I got my
battle pass thing I got my god role
Martis I'm happy I got it work or
autoloading and demolition I'm happy man
and dumb all I got my god roll fusion my
line in the sand rapid hit and firing
line nice I think all I'm working on I
just need steel feather repeater yeah
yeah it's gonna get steel feather
there's some good charge options I think
- yeah I said I got my goggles I'm good
to go I got my smart my sauce st. of the
whatevs a patriot whatever the scout
you got to ask a patron of lost causes
yeah yeah do you have that one I don't
have a good roll on and I just
I've got roll get that done so we can
get you off that diet dadbod gonna noise
nobody goes around saying go figure is
the best gun in the world by the way
it's solid wood a god roll it's solid
but it's not like the one that you hear
be like oh that thing's broken
no it's just like I have a great roll on
it so it's like it is my gun hold on not
not your stop with this he said with
trials being out for more than a year is
why I have a bad feeling it could be
batteries no battle royal bed first of
all destiny would blow up trying to have
more than [ __ ] PlayStation 4's would
take off I think melt there's no way
they can even to handle no type of mode
like that there's nothing there's not
enough CPU and a ps4 and an Xbox 1 s to
try and process like well supers go
exactly they would fry listen it'd be a
six box X X Y series X I can't I'm never
gonna call that the right thing what is
it from the Xbox man is that Xbox series
X or I thought it was the serious X and
this is the Xbox like no no you got Xbox
series X yeah ok mm-hm
not yang got none to worry about bra
nobody's gonna be they will not need
know about it is trolley this bad boy
Royale they wouldn't even call it Trials
quality it would be something different
it would be its own thing
it would be like reckoning where you get
to play that who knows it was your own
thing whatever it is now ascendant
shards enhancement prisms are they in
trials Awards hmm
any other moons mm-hmm I say no I say no
I thought it would be cool it would be
cool but I say no a stick that we get a
sandbox update where those materials you
mentioned will be added to other
activities but like they gotta go
somewhere else I'm getting yeah they
gotta go so in trials I think they're
just gonna leave it specifically for you
know trials when I'm in trial stuff what
if I just play PvP stuff and I can't
really go after those 989 Falls are they
not gonna be is that not the perfect
place to put them in PvP
beer endgame pinnacle PvP activity
listen I would like it I mean I'm not
gonna be upset if I'm saying this is not
later do you think they will I'm saying
do you think it should be there oh yeah
absolutely it should be yes yes and I
want to shout out sinister you know he
made some good points
you know trials mods yeah you know
trials and mods are these gonna be PT
these armor gonna have specific mods to
help you in trials help you raise faster
help you know it's like so what are your
possible pvp specific purchases most
things really are mmm majority PvE
related I would just say stuff that help
specifically for the mode you know um
outside of rezzing yeah there's the
resin factor you know maybe there's
something well they used to have like
traction and stuff like that but that's
useless on PC um so I would say
something to the fact you know maybe
there's some cool ones that hey you know
like number vigilant swing works if you
lose a teammate or whatever if you're
the last one down you get a little bit
more buff on handling or whatever it may
be you know I'm saying so um you know I
know you're right I mean I think one the
the mats need to happen or PvP pinnacle
activity you know what I'm saying and um
yeah oh the last point I want to make
and this directly trials directly
effects this is crucible as a whole
because if we're gonna bring trials back
right and I want to shout out low known
as he made a good point to it I agree
you can't have all these zillion Q's of
crucible you have to have trials
really got a re-imagined what
competitive is now during the week you
really got to imagine you got to really
get on that what what are we defining as
competitive you know I'm saying what the
rewards are for that they need to be a
real and it needs to be a condensing you
can't have nine modes you know I'm
saying
so get it down to two or three you know
I'm saying figure out what you want to
do a competitive and as well as trials
you know saying because you can't leave
it how it is right now
and just add trial to say yeah it
crucible cuz it's too segmented it's all
over the place that that it has to be a
consolidation that that's my last you
know I'm saying what's up say free no
doubt thanks for the string guys got
about half a day's day that's what's up
yeah they gotta had that I mean childís
it as they say and cold type yeah yeah
you know you you can have some cool
things you know that could work in
conjunction with other Guardians and um
if your teammates are wearing these muds
fill in the blank hobo three-man team
stuff yeah mmm mmm this post grenade
yeah recovery rate they got stuff they
can play with you know I'm saying they
definitely got stuff it they it is it's
gonna be fun man I'm not worried about
the ball I'm not worried in the least
I'm just worried about you know what
that reward been working sound cool is
the juice worth the squeeze there you go
and I want to look like a feral it's
like the title of this episode is the
Jews wear this crease let's go that's
not a gap when I was a child at the
better stick buddies all because this
the part I was we've seen a little
screenshot popped up with the worthy
quest that you've got to do that gives
you the title data mining the hex code
so you can see what text rings are out
there mm-hmm
yeah shout the dado recovery teammates
quicker mod or whatever yeah I mean we
used to have like stuff like that you
know they used to have stuff but it was
an exotic that debt well just long in
the stag or making a comeback oh you
know the stag is gonna be lit its trials
without self res holy crap
move it oh no friends just God that was
annoying oh you know what they had to
light beyond never sort of light beyond
nemesis I was one of my favorite warlock
what did it do it residue superfast
oh right sponsor us have to speed yeah
that was a huge deal no rut well you
can't run by res anymore you have to
stand yeah yeah but mister job I raised
my virus
they're like again sniping is pushing
pushing your buddy out of the way like
sliding them once you get them resident
and yet res sniped and stuff yeah I
wonder like the precision damage the
guns I'm just very curious how it feels
I'm not saying the medes bad it does
have like variety and stuff no it does
like nice you go through and you've got
different things but I mean if you get
into the like the sweaty iron banners
mmm god there's a lot of like Lord of
wolves have run around if you gotta
close like there are certain ones that
do it and I know there always will mine
is just more like sniping was part of
trials big time yeah and I don't feel
it's as much in the as much to a point
but there's also get peeled Oh feels
like provoker is gonna be damn popular
revocable of it oh my call the cops
right now on those two Stoke bro they're
too busted we gotta take him to jail
it's a I don't know sniper oh yeah they
really like the fire trucks are out now
man it is legit up there they're calling
the whole National Guard has come in we
got to take them out
you gotta move man you just gotta move
listen that's the problem when you live
on your other one of the busiest streets
and I live next to a firehouse I
literally live next I hope you get a big
discount on your rent for a living next
to that man because absolutely like
every hour in the middle of the night
I'm up I'm down
luckily back that active considered like
noise canceling headphones blackout
curtains and also a coffin like a
vampire to sleep in that a sound
deadening with like two air holes with
drills yeah they gotta have all that
stuff sniper just as snipers are in a
good bro
I was sniping with izanagi's burning
like not to be no sniping is in a good
place
crest of alpha low fee yeah but you know
about that like it that's what's so cool
about chance cuz there's gonna be
certain exotics that will have life in
that mold there's a there's very few
things when it's like I don't want to
worry about dying for it to beat for
something to happen what's the one where
you like you die and you make a rift on
your corpse so many little me I wouldn't
if the RAM makes a little come off so
many fun exotics like I can't wait I
mean I've been excited is it is it ever
gonna be perfect no and I'm saying are
people going to find some next place of
course it's just how people are it's
sweaty people with the gear people are
gonna do what they got to do I get it
but at the end of the day the cool thing
you have to admit though to in this era
that is better than any d1 trials the
minute they find any foolishness your
guns getting turned off switch now so
can you do any exploiting foolishness
without exotic you're getting you've
written to gain your exotic turned off
for the week do we figure out what to do
which so Telesto don't get cute don't
think it's gonna be some fun in there
you gonna get turned off - I'm ready
we're let's go and shout the bungee
please if you hear me if you listen to
this podcast all you gotta do
put Osiris shirts black and gold
eyeballs this man's gonna file Chapter
seven bankers let's do that my god
throws money at screen I want to come to
gcx listen to me on I want to be fully
decked out in Osiris gear so yeah I
could see me I could see me that's how I
want this to be I want to buy everything
I'm seizing we're gonna be honest I
think guys what we need to do is get a
gofundme going this needs to come in
pause play man needs to come in Osiris
no I Brotherhood like Danny no Cyrus
hoodie I mean the hoodie I need the
yellow with don't my god you would wear
that hoodie - oh you know I'm really
with the feather crap let's go these
wear that in public and let me connect a
video of the people who see you walking
notice they respect the drip oh I'm Luke
Smith's brother listen man I'm telling
y'all I will every amount of swag that
y'all create cog will show his
appreciation and buy it oh you guys
house but like a thousand dollar golden
statue in there for me just for him
oh gee do I was brother Vance before I'm
the real brother brother come I've never
thought this day would happen how long
we been doing flashpoints last last word
its bro this is like Christmas bro I am
so happy I can't edits my man it's it's
literally every way I wanted it to
happen it happened and I'm like the evil
sock big face girl is out of here no
more fall before no more primaries we
got a good matter we fast now oh man
wins a season of the worthy ends goes
away yeah why you go lady and drift or
come out to finish up the season as we
face the space Doritos that know it goes
trials bro okay so here you go crush my
joy with this trials comes back it's in
its great state AMD 3 comes out trials
doesn't go in with it
come on help me
that's as you as a as a friend you
should not put those thoughts into
existence all right you know as a good
friend of my father my brother Osiris I
would not put live okay so like what if
it gets to that point where we die as
Guardians
you know the lore that we saw in the
corner some time we've been killed
somehow we get to that point
what if trials is doesn't have the same
probably can have these negative
connotations with mush like while we
don't talk about your what if tea honey
comes out and they get rid of dungeons
oh hey I would write trials if it comes
stays for sure no question not a
seasonal activity this is the guard is
back that God is back and then I do like
sinners are saying the throne of Osiris
chair it's about 10,000 accost fine it a
million a million in games so right now
every bit of Osiris merchandise boom
Nats this man takes out a second
mortgage for game if they are gold
chains with the eye on it I'm buying it
they got hats they got gaming chains you
got the old please telling you I'm
telling if they got tights I'm buying
the decide I'm pulling up with you Cyrus
one you're gonna be showing brain dude
you act like you don't know me but
that's my podcast Ben I'm gonna pull up
with it they're full of it I'm not gonna
know him if he is wearing oh we taking
their pictures we take it everything you
got to take you
there's gonna be a me shaped cloud
leaving a theme if you try that way this
is my date is about move it
hey Alan oh this is great can't wait
I think we've speculated on enough we
won't know much until much more comes
honestly so leaks have been probably
kind of hit that are there know we'll
have a quest coming imperium goes next
week farm as much fractal line as you
can everybody dunk on that fractal and
get ready to get those weapon frames in
again check before you dunk all that
fractal and be like cool I donated 5000
without getting those weapon frames
picked up make sure that's a thing you
guys get involved in because that could
be a huge deal you could be it like
well five thousand fractal 1/400 I'm
just not gonna do that math real fast
like you could do like quite a few damn
weapons though it's gonna be too crazy
like that's something you guys do not
want to miss out on though yes
make sure next week when you logged in
check what the best way to turn that
stuff is is in stay tuned I'll check on
the video see if that stuff is live but
thank you guys podcast has been amazing
this week quick wrap-up and then we will
get you guys out of here because we are
closing new hours and I will see you
guys over to say hey to Connie unicorn
horse man just hilarious man in general
but what do you got sir let's wrap this
thing for me I'm sorry but I was going
to check out the gdl here's idea is I
can take you down yep I'm sitting right
now I'm spending my money thank you sir
of GTO who else if you don't seal shout
out they're not nutty already but we
have a foot age of grizzly all the trial
swag I just had to shout the shadow of
that they'd likely be a ridiculous oh
yeah you already know that sir no I
Cogley don't want Twitter you already
know and um our Lord podcast Sunday 1:00
p.m. Eastern news ever
babies a couple of special guests
returning guests you know I'm saying we
should have my brother Hogue ma you know
I'm saying hopefully he should come in
we talked the legalities of gaming we'll
get that going some stuff going on and
of course my brother Nintendo girl he
might make us stand by I stopped by the
at the realm so check us out at gun
Sunday's 1:00 p.m. Eastern Iowa podcast
YouTube and please support Lords of
gaming dotnet man we'd really appreciate
it you're killing it with the articles
your boy is media you know saying we're
gonna be hitting up packs you know oh
and of course make sure you roll it with
the ready go this Sunday's Super Bowl
Sunday ed up see chairs my boy eats yes
let's go 9 a gang let's go 9 again it is
time baby let's take it back to San Fran
we meet this within the same for the
Super Bowl it's gonna be a crazy well
man pulling for my boys hopefully they
get it done oh I can't wait he we gonna
go crazy if they win this they better go
get out of here vagabond I'll get that
get that crap out of here mondo fire
don't you talk that slander in here no -
a dramatic yeah bad so yeah please Super
Bowl weekend grizzly come on grizzly
what's going on we would do it so well
into you
you put those foul words in the chat
[Laughter]
that's what I got it is that's hot that
MC trip is high oh that's it but that's
what I got man and again thank you for
the support
kick-ass dad shoes Lord gave me dinette
all that good stuff and yeah and of
course of the best damn destiny podcast
did Shui heard yes that last just
literally they just heard it
I hope they heard it they heard me it is
a man yeah so that's what I got yeah he
bonds us everywhere twitch Twitter
YouTube I have been streaming as much
work has been a little crazy trying to
stay up with that so thank you guys I'll
tweet out when I am trying to go live
but which has been a little light but
the videos have been - just been kind of
an off lake not as much as a cover I'm
not trying to just like do some things
and the work has been crazy family just
trying to be a decent husband so all
those things but you guys know thank you
guys for always tuned in and making
these awesome so these are some of like
the best times of the week taking it
with you as well so Super Bowl this
weekend what that 49ers victory as well
so then I'm gonna be going for if not we
just shutting down the podcast next week
and hey we need to recover the video
they were doing yep well that's about
all we got guys so for episode 89
January 31st first month of the decade
is pretty much in the books but thank
you guys have an awesome one enjoy your
weekend root for the Niners not the
Chiefs guys right
and for this episode it has been the
last word